[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein einfaches rezept ich
habe einen auflauf gemacht mit makkaroni
also nudeln und ich hab hier noch hosen
cool dabei ist zurück und ein bisschen
käse
das ganze geht super schnell und ganz
einfach und meine zuschauer wünschen
sich auch immer gerne rezepte die man
super vorbereiten kann und diese auflauf
bis zum rezept also man kann wirklich
morgens zum beispiel alles zusammen
mischen dann enkel schrank stellen und
am abend einfach nur noch auf backen und
dann hat man ein fertiges leckeres
rezept in nur wenigen minuten
ich denke ich mal die zutaten die ich
dafür benötige für den auflauf traurig
350 gramm nudeln ich nehme hier
makkaroni 30 gramm butter 30 gramm mehl
300 milliliter milch 200 milliliter
gemüsebrühe
hier habe ich noch frischkäse muskat
salz pfeffer und thymian
ich brauch 150 gramm zucker 150 km
rosenkohl an dem ich den aus der
tiefkühltruhe 100 gramm kaffee also
krawall käse und 100 gramm schafskäse
zuerst gebe ich jetzt die makkaroni in
salzwasser und lasst sie etwa drei bis
vier minuten garen also so etwa die
hälfte der garzeit so dass sie noch
richtig schön bis haben und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich mich schon mal um
die bälle zu kümmern
dafür gebe ich die butter jetzt hier in
einem topf schmelzen
hier kommen die etwas mehr dazu und dann
mache ich eine mehlschwitze also ich
höre das mich so lange bis die farbe
verliert also so ein bisschen den
geschmack verliert aber farbe annimmt so
geht einfach dieser typische mail
geschmack ein bisschen weg es wird doch
braun
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die mehlschwitze mit der
gemüsebrühe ablöschen dann ist da
vorsichtig sein dass es nicht spritzt
das weiß auch meine selbstgemachte
gemüsebrühe die ich in meinem
kühlschrank gehabt und die habe ich
einfach mit ein bisschen wasser
aufgegossen
da kommt jetzt noch die mädels mit rein
dann mit muskat abschmecken
salz und pfeffer beim salz aber
aufpassen wegen der gemüsebrühe dies ja
auch schon salzig und auch thymian mit
rein
jetzt darf die soße einmal kurz
aufkochen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den herd bereits
ausmachen die nudeln habe ich auch schon
abgegossen die gebe ich jetzt eh mit
rein schön verteilen
dann gehe ich den frischkäse mit zur
sauce und holten kurz ein
jetzt kann ich sie ist total kurs klein
schneiden und den rosenkohl auch halb
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich die soße direkt über die
nudeln und vermischte auch gleich so ein
bisschen und ihr könnt auch gerne jetzt
zu grund in rosenkohl direkt mit
rheinischen ich lege aber ein paar
stückchen gern noch oben drauf damit man
später auch auf dem foto ein bisserl was
geht nur für euch
[Musik]
hier stehe ich jetzt noch den schafskäse
drüber und den zerbrösele ich einfach
ein bisschen mit der hand der schafskäse
ist echt super cremig und vor allem sehr
würzig
[Musik]
mit streich hier noch den cut käse
darüber das ist ein cash carry käse und
er schmilzt einfach richtig schön
ähnlich wie gouda
und so kommt er auch noch jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen und kann gebacken
werden
[Musik]
so sieht er auch läuft jetzt aus das ist
natürlich nur meine variante ihr könnt
das ganze auch vegetarisch machen ohne
job worauf wird es schreit nein niemals
ihr könnt auch gerne rosenkohl
austauschen durch ein anderes gemüse und
einfach eingeben was ihr möchtet morath
holt gerade noch die kinder ab von
kindergarten und schule
er hat auch schon feierabend das heißt
wir können gleich zusammen essen ich
richte jetzt schon mal den tisch falls
ihr das rezept nachmachen möchte schaut
auf meinem blog auf sallys - blog.de
vorbei ich wünsche euch einen guten
appetit und uns auch bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]